Hey, welcome to the DDPS TDPs seminar everyone Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules and logistics. First, please mute yourself during the talk unless you have questions. If you do have questions, you're welcome to unmute and ask otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions so that we can address them in the q&a session at the end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to external audiences. So no close by discussion is allowed. And finally, the talk today will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now, let me introduce our speaker today. It is an honor to host Soledad Vilar, who is an Assistant Professor of Applied Mathematics and Statistics at Johns Hopkins University. She did her undergraduate studies at Univer University, US university, the Republika Rakhi, and her PhD in mathematics at UT Austin. Afterwards, she held postdoctoral position at UC Berkeley, and New York University in 2019. She was selected as a rising star in computational and data science or research is funded by NSF. We're now Amazon and Siemens Foundation today. So that we'll talk about the passive symmetries of machine learning, which is a pity will be very interesting. So please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk. And now without further ado, let me pass the baton to. So that by asking one random person, as usual, today's random question is, what is your superpower? That people don't usually have? Can you pick one? Here with us? Why well, okay, so, um, so, um, I think that something that unusual, I don't know if it's a superpower, but something unusual for me is that I'm from a small country in South America, which is all the way. And that's it. It's interesting, because I think that you get a different life experience than other people just because you come from like, a very unusual place. So people get very surprised about it. Thank you, so that, you answer that, wow. The stage is yours. So, okay, so I'm going to talk about the passive symmetries of machine learning. And what I heard about the audience is that you're mostly physicists, working on machine learning, related stuff with physics. So I don't really need to give you the first live about deep learning and how it has done amazing things change the state of the art in several domains. This is just like an introductory slide. When I say, well, people do amazing things with deep learning, image classification, playing with reinforcement learning, and lately, the there has been this development and protein folding. And my claim is that in all these models, a key insight is the use of symmetries and, and also the use of over parameterization. So first, I'm going to discuss a little bit about over parameterization. And then the main part of my talk is going to be about symmetries. And you know, in, in deep learning, we have these models that we use to fit the data, and they're very well parameterize. So we have maybe more parameters than data points, significantly more parameters than data points. So we have a training set, which are like, say, images on their labels. And then we have a hypothesis class, which is what functions we use to fit the data. So for instance, a convolutional neural network with 42 layers or something like that. So we train the model and we obtain one classifier for my image classification network, which is like one choice on the space of parameters, one choice on the space of weights. So there are many functions in this hypothesis class of possible 42 layer neural networks that can fit the data and even they can fit the data perfectly. So how do you choose the right one? How do you make sure that your optimization model or like your demonstation algorithm finds a function that satisfies that that not only fits the data, but also generalizes. Well, and so there's a notion that people described in the machine learning community, which is called the inductive bias, which is like, like, what is the right assumptions on your model and your optimization algorithm, so that the algorithms are used, they're typically based on local optimization converges to a good solution. Namely, that not only fits the data well, but also it generalizes to the that he hasn't seen before, for instance, a test set that may have the same distribution as the training set or different one, and so on. There's a lot of interesting work that had happened in in the past years regarding over parameterization. And how, what happens with using models that are very well parameterised. And so I have a few like, plots or like drawings from papers in the literature. So one that I like very much, and you probably know about it is called Understanding deep learning requires rethinking generalization. And this model, in this paper, what shows is that these over parameterize, machine learning models can feed data, any data that you want, they can feed a DL zero training error, and they can feed things like, like noise, they can feed the shuffle images with shuffled pixels, they can fit images with the wrong labels, and the fact that they can fit anything tells you that well, the fact that they can do it, why do they generalize? Well, and there's the there's some explanations that had to do with like, how fast they can they can be trained, and how well they generalize. After that. There's, there's other works, what is the double descent work and there's also the benign over fitting work that people like people there at Berkeley, that that basically they show that in over part in our parameterize Moore's you may get some something that they can be explained as they have better generalization. The idea is that in the classical statistical regime, you can feed your, you you have a regime where like you do underfitting regime where you do overfitting. And then when the capacity of the model is like, the sweet spot, then you get the bias versus optimal bias versus variance tradeoff. And that's the best model that you can get, like the lowest risk that you can get for this model. And what they show is that if you do over parameterize models, in some settings, you can go below beyond this, this low bar, and then get some performance that is better than the classical optimal with video with parameterize moles. That's what it means. And that's what they call the double dissent and the benign overfitting phenomena. But all that to say that over parameterize models have very weird performance on they have very interesting mathematical properties. And just the design of the class of functions and optimization algorithms that you're using is key for having a model that performs well, not only on the training data, but also in the general test data or general problem in general. And so there's the notion of like the quality correct or a good inductive bias. So how do you design models so that they actually perform well. And so there's this recent book by brown stain Bruna and collaborators that is called geometric deep learning. And basically, they claim that you can exploit the structure of the input data and if the input problem or on the problem, so that in the design of the models so that they perform well, like that would give you a good inductive bias, for example. So for instance, convolutional neural networks are designed to work well with images and they have a symmetry property, which is that they are translation equivariant would like if you're seeing a cat and you translate this cat to the side, then the the fact that they CNN is translation aquarium is is a property that is useful for image classification. It kind of encodes the semantics of the of the actual problem. And then for instance, recurrent neural networks. This is blood, some sort of translation symmetries. And then graph neural networks exploit a symmetry that has to do with symmetries that are like it doesn't it doesn't I don't know how you express the graph as an adjacency matrix, that's a passive symmetry. And I'm gonna explain in the next in the next slide, what are the passive symmetries. So, in the physical sciences, you may or may not agree with me, and this is something that we can discuss is that there exist two types of symmetries, the active symmetries, which are the symmetries that come from the observed regularities of the physics. So, for instance, images that have to do with conservation laws according to not no other CRM. So, for instance, the fact that if we have conservation of energy, that is equivalent to say that there's a time translation symmetry, my dynamical system, or a conservation of momentum, which is equivalent to a translation symmetry, and a conservation of angular momentum, which can be equivalent to a rotation symmetry. So, those are the active symmetries, symmetries that are observed regularities of the physics, and then have to do with modifications that we can do to the world and observe that something is preserved after we do this modification. And there's also the passive symmetries that are symmetries that are not symmetries of the world, by symmetries that come from the fact that when I express this physical object, in mathematical terms, the choice of expressing this object in math is not unique, I have to make a choice. And then if I do a transformation in my choice, then the word doesn't change. So this transformation should be translated in to the physics into the observer, like into observations as well. So for instance, if I express this object with some set of coordinates, and then I later come back and I express the same object with a different coordinate coordinate system, then the then the observables should be consistent with the change of coordinates that I express. And this includes, like units equivalents, as well, gauging variances and covariances, etc. So these are symmetries that are just like they come from the fact that there's not a unique representation. So they chose that the representation induces some symmetries that will show up. And for instance, say I have a physical system, and I make some predictions based on everything expressed in every mass expressing in kilograms, if I change it to pounds, then the, the data will change. And the predictions will change in a predictable way. That's what it means. Like that's an example of a classic passive symmetry. And so the claim is that the machine learning and data science methods should be consistent with the symmetries in order to be correct. So you, you want to parameterize the space of functions, so that they satisfy the symmetries of the petroleum, they add things seem at this underpass of symmetries. And so an example that is very, is very common in machine learning right now, and people in this is a very active area of research is the graph, neural networks or graph learning. And the passive symmetry, it's a very simple symmetry. The idea is that whatever learning function that I express in a graph, so I have my graph, and then I expressed this graph as an adjacency matrix. And so this is one possible adjacency matrix, the representation of the graph is an adjacency matrix is not unique. So I could choose a different ordering of the of the nodes in my adjacency matrix, and it represents exactly the same graph. So if I take this, this graph representing this way, and I do permutations of these rows and these columns, then I obtain this graph, this this representation, and it's just a different way to represent the same object. So the function that I learned should be consistent with respect to that change. So if it's like say, if I'm just learning a number, say the length of the shortest path, then that number should be invariant with respect to this permutation. So what I'm saying is that f of pi a PI transpose should be equal to F of A as anybody and function for all pi permutations. So this is the action of the permutation on the input space, and then the function needs to be invariant with respect to that action. Or if I'm learning like a node embedding. So I'm learning some property for each node, then that node embeddings should be equivalent with respect to these permutation action, meaning that if I permute, the rows and the columns of my matrix, then then bang needs to be permuted as well. And this is an equivalence so the same group acts on the input and in the output. They don't necessarily act on the same way, but it's just like that it acts as so the question is, how can we efficiently parameterize this space we might even find equilibrium functions With respect to permutations, and this is what people do in, in graph neural networks on graph learning. And so there are many interesting research questions in graph learning that have to do with like how to parameterize the functions that on graphs are equivalent. So the typical way of doing this is by implementing in the form of message passing. So because if you if you write, like message passing is just like you learn a function, which is a message function that each node send to their neighbors, and that there's another function, which is the aggregation function, that each node like aggregates a message from their neighbors, and that is a very simple way to express something that does not depend on the representation of the graph is a matrix. So it's the equivalent just like definition, it's just like, you need to know who your neighbors are. And that's it. So these folks, this is like the classical way of doing good accurate networks. And, and but then there's like a very interesting area of research that says like, actually, if you just implement these, these message passing networks, there are many functions that cannot be expressed by them, even though they're equivariant with respect to permutations are invariant. And the reason is, because like this, this action by the permutations is connected with the graph isomorphism problem, and graphism have some problem is not an easy problem. So you may like just just the complexity of this class of functions is not sufficient to separate non isomorphic graphs. So 39 isomorphic graphs. So there's like a lot of work, trying to understand what functions one can express with these models, or how you can modify these monads so that they can express more functions. And then some functions like for instance, classical message passing neural networks are not able to compute trivial, trivial functions, like the number of triangles in a graph. And so like, you have to think a little bit more. And there's like many interesting words in this space. Yeah. And so and other questions that people have studied, are the stability of the graph neural networks, how do you track and how can you evaluate the transferability? So say, What happens if I train a graph in your network on a graph, they have 100 nodes and then evaluate them and graphs that have 1000 nodes? How can we say that what this graphing network is doing is consistent. And then there's a lot of work on like the evaluation of the performance of graph networks, in benchmarks, which are being developed and also in in theoretical models, like random graph models. But that's that, so that's kind of like a connection between like, some passive symmetry and or some symmetry, and then a model that relies on the symmetry, which is graphing networks and a lot of mathematic interesting mathematical problems come from the actual symmetry of these models. And there's, that's just graphing networks. And this is a an big part of my research, but I'm not going to focus on it on on the stock. i We can talk about it offline, if you want. Or, or maybe if you have any questions. I'm happy to answer them that now. But I'm just gonna, so the idea for my talk today was to describe other symmetries that have to do with scientific machine learning. Any question? Okay, so, so why in machine learning has to do with the understanding of the symmetries that go into the machine learning models, and the applications include, like, dynamical systems, fluid dynamics, graphs, I just mentioned that particle systems, in particular, for instance, protein folding Alpha fold, uses equivariant transformers in part of the architecture. So it really shows up in many scientific applications. And just, it's not just graphs, it goes beyond that. So I'm going to explain other ways that symmetries go into the definition of machine learning models and how to implement them and on how to evaluate them. So the so if I have time, I'm going to describe how to implement different equilibrium models and political systems, how to implement it with violence on images. And I have a few applications. One is a toy example that is easy to see what's going on. And then we have applications to cosmology and to vegetation dynamics that I can describe Ah, yeah. So can I ask the question? Yes. So earlier you had mentioned that this this difference between these active and passive symmetries. An interesting example for a physical system would be where if I'm thinking about an active symmetry, how can I get conservation of energy by implementing the right set of symmetries in my modeling or wherever? So that energy is conserved? Is that also part of the consideration here? Yes. So I'm gonna I have an example on the at the end of my talk where we do that. But the idea is that if you if you know that your system is coming, Tania, then you can, you can use something like a neurology that does Hamiltonian integration. So then they like the fact that there's a, there's a constant Hamiltonian is already embedded in the model. So the energy conservation is part of the definition of your of your model. Okay. Okay. Thanks. Yeah, I look forward to that example. So, okay, so how do we implement symmetries? Okay, the classical thing that people do is to data mentation. But I'm going to focus on like architectural design, which is like, I'm going to restrict the learning to the class of functions that satisfy the symmetries. And the way people do it is by using weight sharing, like for instance, message passing is a form of weight sharing. Because it's the same message that goes to to every node, the message function, not the same message, but the same function, then there is an approach based on a producer representations that I'm going to describe very briefly. And then I'm going to go into the idea of using the invariant theory for that. So so the idea is, so we have a group action, and maybe I should have like a little drawing, like here. So say, maybe either before or not, yeah, here, I think I skipped the slide. So the idea is that you have a group that acts on a data set. And then if you, if you apply the group action to the input, and then the output doesn't change, then you say that is invariant. So for instance, in this image classification, if you rotate the image, then the classifier doesn't change, or equivariant. So for instance, here I have this particle system, and I have I want to predict the dynamics. So if I rotate this particle system, then the predictions will rotate. And they do have equivariant ML is that the hypothesis class satisfy that for every choice of parameters. So for every data for every function, you in your hypothesis class, it satisfies this symmetry, so for every day that f of g times x is equal to g times f of x, for instance, here. So that's the idea. So the question is, how do you implement that as a function that satisfies this property? So one way of doing that is by saying, Okay, I'm gonna start with a feed forward neural network, which is the composition of linear functions or nonlinear activation functions. And then I'm going to restrict the linear functions, so so that they satisfy the symmetries. And so they're, since they're not done many linear functions that are symmetric, like say, if you say, like, rotation invariant functions, how many linear functions are rotation invariant? Not very many. So so then what you do in order to make the space of functions expressive, is you extend these two tensors. So you say, okay, the linear functions are not just going to take a vector, but they are going to take a tensor of the input with itself k times, and they're going to output the tensor with a weight of the input with itself, k prime times. And so you want to look at the functions that are linear, under equivariant, here by just extending the action to each of the orders of the tensor. And the question is, how do you do that? And one person that that did a lot of this work is test net, which I think was working for you at some point recently. So, she, she developed many of these methods. And, and the thing that she does is, she uses representation theory. So the idea is that how do you parameterize these linear functions that are equivariant in this tensor spaces, and basically they do this idea based on group representations, which basically says that if you have an equi via map, and then that is linear, then you can use some properties from like, representation to you theory that says that if you take take your space and decompose the space in the in the reducible components, then this tensor space, you decompose it in the irreducible components with respect to a group action, then a map is equivalent, even a leaf in maps, it will also component of the same type to itself by a multiple of data entity. So, the idea is they take the space the space that's tensor space, they they compose the the input and the output in the reusable components. So they have these rules or representations. And then from these reusable representations, they just read off, what are the possible parameterizations that send one space into the next. And that's a paper by Thomas and Smith, collaborators in 2018. They have a very nice implementation, I think in TensorFlow. But, but the hard part of this approach is that in order to do this composition of this tensor product into irreducible representations, you need to be able to compute the claps Corbyn coefficients, which is, is known in some cases, but it's hard to do in general. So, so yeah, so yeah, so to summarize, the idea is to take a feed forward neural network, and you replace the layers, the linear layers by linear equation layers on dinosaurs, and then you use irreducible representations to parameterize, the linear goodbye of layers on these tensor spaces. That's the idea. There's another question of like, how do you choose the not the activation functions, and that depends very depends on the group that you're using, in some cases is easy, but in some cases, it's hard to to find nonlinear activation functions that work. So that's, that's a reducible representation approach. My, my focus is different is a different approach to the same problem, which is the invariant theory approach. And I think it's simpler, but it works in some for some simple league groups, that people using classical physics, but in general is not known what the invariants are. So it may be harder to do in general. Whereas the rules of representation approach works in general. So it is the following. So we have this, this particle system over here. And the goal is to start just for simplicity. So we have N particles in rd. And our goal is to find all the barium functions that take these n particles in rd and output a scalar. So we could look at the OD which is Altana group, or rotation rotations, which are like all these they rotations and reflections. And then there's the Lorentz group, which is, is a similar group, but it has a different inner product. And it comes from special relativity. And the idea is that the function that we want to parameterize satisfies that if I rotate all my inputs, the function doesn't change, because it's an invariant function. So in order to do that, we can go back to the classical work in group theory by trial, that shows that the first fundamental theorem for immodium theory says that a function is all the embodiment if and only if you can write it as a function of the pairwise inner products of your inputs. This is kind of intuitive, right? So I have a point out, so I take the pairwise inner products of my inputs. And then I write the function on that. So if I rotate the point, well, the pairwise inner pros of the inputs don't change. So the function that I write is going to be embedded with respect to rotations? Or the the question that we need to ask is like, is that all? Does that Is that sufficient to write all the functions that are embedded with respect to rotations? And the answer is yes, and there's many ways to see it. But but that's basically the idea. So that gives you a very simple way to parameterize just the environment function. So for instance, if I want to learn the energy of the particle system, then I can write it as a function that I learned on the pairwise inner products of the positions on velocities of my of my of my point cloud and that will be invariant with respect to rotations. So if I want to write not just like just a scalar function, but I want to write for instance, predict the day dynamics of this point cloud, what I can do is I can parameterize the learning as a as an equilibrium function. So say for instance, for each particle, or for the center of mass, what I need to learn is a function that takes these n vectors in rd. So the point cloud and output vector in rd that is equally valuable respect to rotation. So if I rotate the input the output rotate. And is, it's not too hard to see that actually, a function is all the equivalent if and only if you can write it as a linear combination of your input vectors times a scalar invariant function. So a function of the inner products as in the previous case. And so this suggests, or more than for the learning, basically, the model is you take your input point cloud, you compute the scalars. And then you learn different functions at once events, so like this, this coefficient functions, and then your output is going to be a linear combination. And you can implement this in many ways you can implement it with attention mechanisms, for instance. And this is part of something that is can be seen in like a more general theory that allows you to translate knowledge from invariance to equivalence. And the idea is basically that the equilibrium functions are the functions that satisfy like that this commutative diagram over here. So say, I have a vector in V. And then if I apply the group action, here, let's see if we will see, yeah, I apply the group action, then. And then I applied the function is the same as applying the function and then applying the group action in the output. So you can see this commutative diagram. And then just knowing that you have a group action in the in the space V. group action displays W induces an action on the space of maps from me to w, so that the equivalent functions are the fixed points. And so that suggests that the knowledge on the invariant maps is sufficient to transport that into knowledge on equilibrium maps. So all that I'm saying, and I'm not going to go into the details of this is that this construction that I showed you earlier, on how to go from, like the body and the the understanding of what the body and functions are, to what the equilibrium functions are, is something that you can do in general, for other for other groups, as well, as well. Now, I'm gonna tell you a little bit about this example, which is like a simple toy example. But I think that it explains how this mole is can be implemented. And maybe other more interesting, we can discuss more interesting problems where these Can, can be used. So in this example, I have like these double pendulum connected with springs. And so the problem is to predict the dynamics at this level pendulum. And so this, this model, this, this, this problem has like a, like an ode to equilibrium. So say, if I do a rotation in the xy plane, then the dynamics of the pendulum rotates in the xy plane. But this model is not all three equilibrium, or at least not in a priori, because if I do a rotation that moves the Z axis, then the model doesn't really doesn't really behave in the same way because of the because of how the gravity affects the dynamics. But if you're if you move the gravity vector with the masses, everything at the same time, then that is oh three, which is that this is kind of like a coordinate transformation. So we can say that if you add the gravity vector as an input to your learning problem, then this is an all three whereby on passive symmetry that you you can implement. So you gotta learn the position and momentum of your of your particles as an all three will function, assuming that the gravity is an input to your model, and maybe the gravity is fixed, which is typically in life, but but still, you you need to be able to compute the variance with the gravity as well. So in this model, this is a Hamiltonian system. So this is this Last time translation symmetry were like they, they come into union kinetic energy plus potential energy is conserved. So if you're going to learn, if you're going to use a machine learning model to learn this, you could say you can implement the rotation symmetry this all three. And also you can implement the Hamiltonian symmetric as well like the, the, and then for that, we have two approaches. So the classical neural od approach, which is basically you learn a differential equation, you say, my data satisfies the differential equation that I'm going to learn from data. So this this there is a derivative of my state with respect to time. And this is an equilibrium function of my input with respect to this, OD, or in this case, oh three. And, and then we can learn that and then we can use our all the integrator to do the predictions. And you, we can learn the parameters of the differential equation using that. So that's one way to do it. And this would just learn an OD. But we can also use the fact that this Hamiltonian is conserved. And so in order to do that, what we do is, we are going to use a Hamiltonian neural network. So we know that the system is coming to an end. So there's a specific, specific differential equation that the data satisfies. So I can just make my model to learn a Hamiltonian, h, which is a scalar function of my inputs, and then use a Hamiltonian integrator to do the prediction of the dynamics. And that incorporates all the symmetries that we were discussing. So I think this is the answer to the question that I got by Ts just earlier that I can't comment much more on this if you want. No, that's okay. Then I understood it. Thank you. Yeah. So so the fact that you use scalars gives you the offeree symmetry. And the fact that you use a Hamiltonian integrator gives you the, the Hamiltonian symmetry. And then other words, like for instance, there's words by Kenny Iraqis that implement for instance, some symplectic symmetry in machine learning models by having specific forms of integrators and specific ways to parameterize the dynamics. So, for this example, this numerical example just shows you here this like this is a like the trajectory of the masses in phase space, these drawings, and these table tells you that the more symmetries you implement, the better the performance you obtain. So here we are obtaining like we are implementing the all three symmetries with the neural early on, they all three symmetries with the Hamiltonian are the, from here to here you are, you're adding one more symmetry, which is the time translation symmetry, and then it works better. And if you go to write this, the groups that that you are using are the symmetries that you're enforcing and weaker, weaker, and this model doesn't impose any symmetries. So for fixed training set size, the more images you implement, the more constrained the learning is, you can show there's math results that tell you that the generalization error is going to be small just because you're constrained to a class of functions that is smaller, and is consistent with the ground truth solution. So that is for the symmetries with respect to rotations are no but other symmetries that have to do with units are also useful and interesting. And, for instance, in this case, and just in this example, what you can do is you can see that you're predicting this coming Tanya, which is an energy and has units, kilograms, meters squares divided by seconds square. So if I do a transformation, my training set, so that everything that had units of kilograms now has units or pounds, or everything that had units of kilograms now is multiplied by five, then this, you know, you can predict how you that would affect the output by just doing dimensional analysis. So that's the scaling symmetry, you can think of it as the group of scalings acting on the input, give you precise known scaling in the output, assuming that all the relevant inputs are in the model and If you do that, then that is another symmetry that you can implement into your model. And one way to do it is by using the Buckingham pi theorem, that tells you that that any function that is units that we wired can be written as a function of dimensionless features. So the idea is you take your input, and then you can do some transformations of your inputs, so that you can construct dimensionless features. So for instance, I can take, like the M, one divided by m two, that's dimensionless. And then you can construct the basis of dimensionless features. And then you can learn a function of your dimensionless features. And, and that's give you a dimensionless label. And then you can use a big scaling to give you the actual dimensional output. And that's something that people do in practice in many, in many applications just working on like the dimensionless formulation of the problem. So for instance, in PDE, s, people do that all the time, just like write it, write it in, in a dimensionless way, so that the scaling is correct. So yeah, so that's the idea. And you can see, I mean, I'm not gonna go into the, into the details of the math, but you can see that this symmetry can be seen as a group like this consistence of the units can be seen as a symmetry with respect to a group action, and the group is a group of scalings that have to do with the number of units that you have in the model in the models. So here, it would be like, if you ever, like things can have units of kilograms, meters seconds, so the action is by our oops, small will be an action by like, our greater than zero to the three, like you can scale the masses, you can scale the distances and you can scale the time. That's, and then if you scale that, then it affects the output by scaling the masses linearly scaling the distances quadratically, and scaling the times we like many to one half negative two. Anyway, so finally, I'm going to discuss how can we mathematically explain how much do you gain by enforcing symmetries. And so, the idea is the following. So if we have if we have a learning problem, and and you have like a task of regression task, then you can define the risk of like the expected value of the of the error with respect to the ground truth. And, and so, the generalization gap is going to be the risk of your function. And so the generalization gap between like a function f and the projection of F onto this basically by the functions is going to be the risk of f minus the risk of the projection of f. And you got to see that under some assumptions, they say the group is compact, and they on the measure that suppose the data is symmetric, then you can actually quantify that the risk, the difference in the risk is always non non negative. And it's like just the norm of the projection of F onto the space of who might have functions. So that shows that you always gain something by imposing symmetries in some way. Because, like, the error that you that you have is decreases by, by something that is how much you throw out when you project into the space of the mind functions. Of course, this has a very strict hypothesis or like assumptions. And it requires that, that you can like understand, like imposing the symmetries is kind of like doing a regression and then projecting onto the space of environment functions. Whereas in practice, people don't do that people just like do a regression into a space of combining functions. So it doesn't really match a projection. But the this is just one way of explaining it. So We have some applications to cosmology. Basically, the idea is that, well, David Hogg is my collaborator, he is an astrophysicist. And Kate is his students. And they work in cosmology. And basically what they have is like a very expensive hydrodynamic simulation. And then they have a cheaper darkmatter only simulation. And so they want to use the cheaper simulation to make predictions of why happens in the in the more expensive simulations. And so what they do is they write a machine learning model to predict the properties of the galaxies in the more expensive simulations, by defining the machine learning model to be respecting this, this symmetry. So they respecting units a group is and respecting rotational equivalences, as well. And they do that by representing the data in a way that has to do with the scalars that we just described before. And they, they show that machine learning models that imposes symmetries, we're better than the ones that do not impose these symmetries. That's the idea. And they, they write it in a way so that the most that they obtain are interpretable. So another application of this is the to vegetation dynamics. I'm not going to go into the details of this application until unless you ask me but basically, the idea is that if you have a simulation of the vegetation dynamics, the things that go into these simulations have a lot of units, because include, like the rainfall and water update, and the vegetation laws, etc, all of them have units. And so if you're, if you do it, you if you do a regression, that is units in Cuba, then you can see that it will perform better. And, um, let me just like show you a little drawing of like how you can extend these two images. And the idea is that when you work on images, you have to use these ideas of scalars, or vectors and tensors. In, in an image setting. So you can use like, you can extend the things that I that I told you about using the scalar formulation for implementing the query and functions to an image setting where like, what you can do convolutions and you combine this convolution idea with this scalars idea. And you can define more or less that satisfy this similar properties and produce nice pictures. So as a summary, and I like maybe five minutes over, say that the enforcing exact symmetries in machine learning give you the correct more or less good noise assumptions, better sample complexity, it's more generalization error. And we can show how to parameterize certain classes of functions that satisfy the symmetries of classical physics, using basically Einstein summation notation. And, and we can extend this to images that say, Thank you for your, your time. Thank you. Thank you so much for your wonderful and informal, informative presentation. Very nice. Very nice. We're going to have a question and answer sessions, we have a 10 minutes. Maybe I can start with a one philosophical questions. So you start with a neural net model, which is over parameterised. So you have a lot more parameters to tweak to represent something, right. So in some sense, you have a overdetermined system with a and you'd like to close the system by introducing some sort of symmetric constraints into your equations, right. So that you can generalize better. What if well, that works when, you know, some system you're dealing with has already, you know, some sort of symmetry has to be there, and you can impose that, right? But what if you don't know the system you're dealing with? You don't? You don't know ahead of time, what kind of symmetry you have to impose. Is there a way you can discover that somewhere Three? Yes, that's a great question. There's a few papers, recent papers that try to learn this image from data. And they they do it at different levels of success. But I think that it's yeah, it's an interesting question. It's, it's not fully salt, like people try to parameterize the symmetries in one or another way, and then learn that from data and then use that for for predictions. Okay, so there are walks out there, I can, I can point out some references. There's reference, like there's some work by the group of Andrew Wilson at NYU, where they do some learning of the symmetries on the fly with that. So basically, they they parameterize the symmetries like using that, like simple things like say, Well, my, my symmetry needs to be implemented as a matrix, which should be local. And then they do like they basically parameterize things in terms of the exponential map, and then they optimize jointly for the most amount of symmetries and the smallest loss for the training error. And then they just tried to do that that way. As as one example. So what if I brought you in San Diego, where they do something similar as well? Rosa, you said, okay, so I know her. Okay, great. So let's go to the audiences. I see. Pat, posted some questions in the chat room? Have you wanna unmute yourself and ask a question directly? Sure. Thank you. Yeah, yeah. Thank you for your talk. So yeah, so you focused on on Earth. Of course, the notion of inductive bias is much more broader than that. And I'm, and it's clear that symmetries can play a role to me than in with many other different representations of learned knowledge. So I just want like to understand how much of your analysis is limited to neural nets, and how much of it is more general. So the this is more general, in the sense that you don't need to use neural nets, you can use any form of regression and impose the symmetries in in that regression. So for instance, the people that are doing the work in cosmology are not using neural networks. They're just using simple models, and they're using their features so that they satisfy the, the symmetries of the problem. Yeah. So that's good. Great, thank you. So the simple model as such as what they are doing some form of like a lasso, like a linear regression with with spicy parts, right. Yeah. Okay. All right. That's it. I had another question about scale invariance. Okay. Yeah. Feels feels very different from me, but what they talk about his invariants. And so I'm curious as to whether there's any weather that comes up here, like scaling empires? Well, I mean, there's there's a branch, there are branches of science that are who are very, very focused on systems that exhibit the same phenomena at any scale. And, and and I want to understand whether that's a different use of the term invariance, or whether it is similar, and there's a way to to model it. And the framework you've proposed so far is this was self similarity of these properties. Yes. self similarity could be phrased in in this in this language. Actually, there's a book by Peter over where they look at the self similarity in differential equations and how we can look at it in terms of groups in variances as well. Okay, thank you. Oh, and Jung Soo, I just wanted to mention that rose, you is giving a talk. Right? Like, like in three minutes at ISI and also the link here. Yeah. You have to register and probably I'll say, I will send a link but you have to register. Or you might invited to this to this seminar. Thank you. All right. I'll try and get the link and put it in the chat box. Yeah, that'd be awesome. Okay, thank you. Awesome. Any other question? I don't see any other questions in chat, but Um, you can ask by unmute yourself. And then yeah. I guess I can ask a question really quick. So part of the coming up with the invariance is is sort of doing this projection to a set of parameters, which are like, in a sense, the minimum set that you need to describe the system that takes into account all of the symmetries and invariances. Right? So like, in the double pendulum example, you have the two invariants. Is there any sort of intuition behind what sort of projection you choose to use as opposed to something like an SVD? Or? So what we do is, once the we know, what is the what is the symmetry, then what we can do is we can write this base of invariant functions with respect to that symmetry. So for instance, why did they so to imbiah functions. And so sometimes there's like, very, like, you can write as the main functions or functions of these, like small features that you can construct simply from the data. So in the case of, say, all three, then if you write any function in terms of the scalars of the inner products of your inputs, then that function is going to be invariant, and vice versa. So that gives you like, I think that's where your question was going. Right? Like, yeah, so what if it's a more complicated set of like, like a conservation law? Something like conservation of energy? Yeah. So if it's a conservation of energy, you're you're probably have, you probably have a Hamiltonian right? That you that you're concerned that you have conserved? Yeah. So what you can do is you can write, and also you know, that it will satisfy a specific differential equation. So you can, you can use the form of the differential equation that it will satisfy, and then learn the parameters that define that differential equation. And then do you just integrate that differential equation? So it's basically you have a parameterization of the functions that satisfy that property, either via the fact that they're, like the scalars are constant? Or be the fact that there's a specific differential equation that the data should satisfy? Maybe you don't know what the parameters are. But if you know that, if you satisfied that specific differential equation, then you know that the energy is going to be conserved. Okay. All right, thanks. Just really quickly, so a lot of us are interested in embedding neural networks inside existing scientific simulations, in which case, we're interested in the networks, not only like representing the physical quantities need to be conserved, but also numerical properties that won't lead to exponential blow up and stuff like that. Do you have any ideas on what kind of symmetries we could employ to represent that? Um, so yeah, this does a tricky question. So for instance, in the case of this, they have the scaling invariance, your urine balance look like quotients of things, and that numerically blows up. So if you want to do like, if you want, if you have that symmetry that has to do with scalings. In fact, you can have like, very small scalings, like you can work at different scales. And that's something that is numerically unstable. So you have to be careful with that. So you would I mean, that that is more of like, how do you do it in practice, so that it doesn't really blow up, you have to be careful. So what we did was, we constructed by and features, and we allow the million features to be within a range. And if the if there wasn't within a range of them, we removed them, since they bind features can be chosen so that they are then you can have more than that than redundant, you can have a redundant set of invariant features, you can remove some invariant features that are ill conditioned and get only use the ones that are well conditioned. And that's sufficient to express the moment. So incorporating redundancies and over parameterization is is better than doing something that that may not have that property. So you can you can remove that ill conditioned behavior by incorporating redundant features. Does that answer your question? I think so. I'm more just I get nervous anytime that I embedded ote and something if I can't guarantee that it's on one half of the complex graph. Yeah, and I wouldn't well they have have a comment about it. Unless it's like something specific that I have done before. You know, I think that it could many problems like that may arise and I maybe haven't thought about them. Sounds good. Any other question? This past two after 11. Maybe it's a time to wrap up. Okay. Okay. Let's, let's thank our speaker today for a wonderful talk and wonderful q&a session. I'm sure there are more questions. But I'm sure you know, all that he's going to be happy to get any questions through email, right? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, of course. Yes. Yeah. All right. Yeah. So thank you so much for Yeah, for inviting me. And I hope that was useful to you. Yeah. And I hope that, you know, after this event is initiating some more collaboration between Lawrence Livermore and your group at Johns Hopkins. So let's hope for that. Thank you. Thank thanks.